my first [ __ ] was okay damn well here
we go
it i know that everyone's all you do is
talk about sex but really well i did
have a good time trying to talk to women
about work
and they just want to tell you i don't
want to hear about the first
blow job i wanted you to say like a
funny place you worked i didn't hear to
hear like the whole backstory of your
sorry no i was intrigued even though i
literally don't remember one detail from
it but um
did you work in an ice cream place now
that i could see you at best can robin
no okay first of all i was not a
cheerleader
dude i would have bought a thousand
scoops i would have let you scoop it
with your hands
yeah that's so nice i really appreciate
that like i
remember taste some of it off your back
that's what i would have said you know
sorry that's out of line i'm sorry so
nice i want to
thank you i like um when people uh
allude to wanting to have sex with me i
think it's like very nice when
it's done in a way that you're just like
when they're just like jokingly saying
it like that means a lot hearing that
from you because i
obviously that's like the struggle of my
life i think is like
wanting to be [ __ ] and also wanting
to be funny and fun and be
in and then people being like god she's
trying too hard to look [ __ ] it's
just like
can i draw i i didn't discover that i
was [ __ ] until very late in life
and i also am not married so who gives a
[ __ ] and whatever but what i was gonna
say about that is like also
i i i even hate being like my first
blood job because people are gonna write
in comments like
all she does is talk about sex she's
just trying to shoe horn to sex right
but this
i actually think it's interesting did
you ever do
uh girl what's that thing sugar girls or
whatever
what's that sugar baby baby yeah theo i
don't know who you think i have sorry
i don't i cannot have sex with someone i
like
like let alone i don't know very weird
about sex
i know i'm fascinated by your stuff with
it as well because i feel like
i look at sugar babies or like only fans
of girls and like
thoughts and girls that are just like
porn stars i like love them all
and i don't um know like
i but i'm still weird about putting that
kind of stuff out there
yeah oh i remember first yeah when i
even got that first [ __ ] i
even remembered asking my buddy to go
with me because i was nervous you know
yeah i mean i guess guys are nervous too
i mean i would assume you guys are
more driven but girls are like i've got
to get this out of the way i just i
didn't give a [ __ ] until i was
a junior in college and all my friends i
was like they were all having sex
relationships i was just like i haven't
even had sex i gotta blow someone so i
was just like
who was it it was a comedian that that's
the interesting part
is it i can't say who it was but it was
a it was see i
i was such a person was he tall or short
medium hmm i bet i know it is i'll tell
you i'll tell you who it is off air but
i can't say it on air i don't want to
know off air
really yeah okay well good i'll tell you
whatever you want to know
because i would trust you but i but i
respect that you don't care
um yeah i don't like knowing some of
that kind of stuff you know
i agree i am actually i like more
mystery
well i like to be able to imagine you
blowing a couple of different people
that i have like i mean my roster isn't
crazy
of people you know but like but that's
the thing everyone's gonna be like she's
such a [ __ ] i literally
i don't think you're a [ __ ] you're also
an adult it's not like you're a child
who's
who's like sneaking into people's houses
and [ __ ] you are a regular adult and
you can have sex i know but if i were
having a lot of sex i would talk about
it it seems like i do because i talk
about sex a lot but i
don't like i haven't had sex in two
years and like what yeah oh we're gonna
get right into that here's a woman right
here that has a question she's obviously
she's not doing well either what's up
so what i've always noticed is a lot of
female comics will start out like their
first like
big hit gig is like a lot of sexual
based humor
um and then as
the you know their gigs continue it's
like a play off of the same
gig and what what pressures do you feel
i guess is like a female comic of like
if your humor is not sexual based like
do people think you're not funny anymore
or like what is that trend about i'm
curious obviously not a comic but
it's something i've noticed you know
with female comics and it doesn't seem
like there's a lot of them
but when there are always always sexual
based yeah
just curious does it feel like that as a
future thank you
that's a great question gang gang and i
appreciate your service over there too i
actually did a show at raf lake and
heath one time
it's a great backhanded question so what
she was referencing
is what a lot of people say is like all
they talk about is sex and it's true
because i mean there's this documentary
called hysterical about female comics
and it's the last thing i'm sure
a lot of people want to watch and i'm in
it
and i did not expect this to be so
[ __ ] good and moving like i learned
i watched it and cried at my own story
like i don't cry and i was like
i saw myself as like oh my god you're
such a scared little girl who doesn't
understand her worth and then i watched
all these
female comics that i'm friends with in
this documentary it's so well done theo
you will actually really like it
and um it's one of i love documentaries
it's really well done and i would not
i'm in a lot of [ __ ] and is it a real
documentary that's on do we can see
it somewhere now well i'm uh yeah it's
called hysterical and it's uh
fx okay and on hulu but honestly this is
not
i if i wasn't in it i'd be promoting it
everyone i told to watch it
who you would think would be like not
into that they [ __ ]
people have overheard me listening to it
but anyway i watched all my friends on
there being like
what drove them to stand up judy gold
rachel feinstein
uh sherry shepard margaret uh who else
uh
bonnie mcfarlane marina franklin fortune
theme sir
it's lazy uh at least yeah yeah
she's in it i love her but we all and
then the girl that stood up to um
harvey weinstein harvey weinstein was at
a [ __ ] open mic that or the show this
girl was doing and she called him out it
was so
brave it's it's [ __ ] good but my
point is female comics talk about sex
at least it's presented in that
documentary because we were like
silenced about our bodies and like
controlled about for so long that
when you talk you want to talk about
like what you've been told you can't
talk about but for me
when it comes to sex i i've done
fallon like stand up on fallon
four or five times at this point i can
do clean material i don't have to talk
about sex
i don't talk about sex in any of that
that's and i've done i've done
tons of like squeaky things and people
go all she she's
filthy the thing is i talk about sex
because i like it i'm not trying to talk
about sex with you today because i
am like trying to be like sexual or
because i don't really i don't think i'm
funny about anything else
it's interesting and no one's talking
about it people still think oh
everything's been talked about it's like
no it hasn't i'm still encountering
things that i'm like
i need someone to process this with me
and for me that is saying it on stage
and having people laugh
and go or have girls go oh my god that
happens to me too i needed to hear that
and like
em empowering girls i just really want
to do with stand up talk about sex
because i want men to know
how we're feeling and i want to
understand how men are feeling so i want
to express what i think men are feeling
and hear if that's right or not right
and like and
be and make people feel better about it
because i'm just the reason i talk about
sex is because i'm so [ __ ] scared of
sex and like
so also want it but also don't want it
and it's like the most interesting thing
well yeah i mean sex is an interesting
thing it's really like a me it's like
i mean it's how we get here also it's
like you don't even exist if somebody
doesn't have sex you know so
that's what yeah the fact that it has so
much magic in it i would be a sex
therapist
if i wasn't a comedian if i didn't have
like talent
and wanted to perform i would still work
in the sex field do you think that women
don't get broad enough with their topics
though
no i think talk about whatever the [ __ ]
you want you know like i
i anything i do now that's what you're
talking about like hobbies and stuff and
feeling you waste time
when i do something now that feels like
if i masturbate now let's say or do
something that i'm like
i'm trying to think of another or get a
massage like i'm getting a foot massage
after this one really i maybe should
work on some stuff i have do
yeah but it's like those things is not a
waste like i want it
or smoking weed when i probably
shouldn't being like
instead of being like you're smoking
weed this is so bad i'm just like
listen i have a life where i choose what
i get to what
to do and so if i'm doing it i must want
to do it it must be serving me in some
way so just
cut the guilt right and just enjoy it so
that i have that per approach now with
sex stuff like i
i will talk about whatever fascinates me
but sex still fascinates me until it
doesn't when my libido
drops when i'm doing stand-up when i'm
60 i probably won't be talking about
[ __ ]
right well we can always check then you
know
um yeah i think it's tough sometimes i
don't like talking about it because it
just seems kind of
vulgar to me sometimes yeah and that's
like so i like thinking about it
sometimes you know
but i don't like really i guess
sometimes i don't like talking about it
but i'm also like
the vulgarity that makes you go but then
that makes you feel shame about right
you're right
it breeds shame you're right hope you
enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one